it's about damn time we step into our
power
it's about damn time we talk about the
fact that guns
have more rights Than a Woman
it's a sad day in America
Taraji P Henson calling out the Supreme
Court's decision to overturn Roe v Wade
at the 2022 BET Awards I mean it that's
all I can say I'm bringing the energy
which we all need right now the actress
who hosted the show used her platform to
send a message first she praised lizzo's
opening performance of her hit song
about damn time
[Music]
thank you to the amazing lizzo right
oh
this body positivity up in here
and also thank you lizzo for pledging
one million dollars to Planned
Parenthood that's right lizzo made that
pledge after the Supreme Court reversed
their 1973 decision to protect the right
to have an abortion Taraji then
referenced the singer song title to make
a powerful statement you're damn right
it's about damn time
it's about damn time we step into our
power
it's about damn time we talk about the
fact that guns
have more rights Than a Woman
a weapon that can take lives has more
power than a woman who can give life if
she chooses to
and it's about time I got that off my
chest I'm bringing love and joy which we
all need right now what's going on in
the world and so tonight we're going to
celebrate us
black excellence and that's what it was
all about for Taraji as she took on
hosting duties for the second time and
that's why we chose tonight we're going
to honor Diddy and we're also going to
uplift all black men yep one of the
biggest moments of the BET Awards was
Diddy receiving a Lifetime Achievement
Award come on about time right he's
incredible and big to the culture after
a few star-studded performances by his
Bad Boy Records artists and himself
included
[Music]
Diddy accepted the honor I gotta thank
every artist every producer every writer
The Hitman every executive I had a
chance to work with thank you so much
thank you to all of my fans who have
been with me for over 25 years
Diddy's son's Christian King Combs and
Quincy Brown talked to E.T backstage
about what it meant to see their dad
being honored I've been waiting for this
moment for such a long time and for him
to finally get his flowers and to be up
there on the big stage doing what he got
to do I was just proud he went crazy
though he did go crazy it's an
emblematic moment moment you know
because like
we at the house with it you know so we
get to celebrate it at home but to
celebrate with everybody you know that
just meant a lot you know I was crying
up there just from being proud and just
like you know all the success all in one
I mean to just salute them at the end of
the day
foreign
[Music]